[Music]
is there a point to this journey of mine
a dog's purpose producer Gavin pallone
opens up about the controversial leaked
video that implied a trainer seemingly
forced a scared German Shepherd into
water when I first saw the video I was
shocked by what I had seen and initially
just worried that something had happened
to a dog on the movie which seemed
incomprehensible to me since the movie
had wrapped shooting a year and three
months earlier and I would have heard
about something like that even if I
wasn't on the set which I was not
immediately I went to investigate to
find out exactly what happened and that
was illuminating but I did find out
after looking at all the footage that
was shot not only by our film cameras
but also by trainers and other people
along the set was that a couple of
things did go wrong on that set and
we're done incorrectly and I was very
upset about it at the same time I also
realized that the video in the way that
it was shot and how it was cut together
was not portraying what happened on the
set completely accurately I've received
threats of violence Bruce Cameron the
author of the book received threats of
violence
the director has had threats of violence
we very much want to show people that
this dog was cared for that the dog
wanted to go into the water that
ultimately when the dog went into the
water was not by being pushed but he
went and did it himself so we so the
studio is trying to figure out a way to
do that and that's in process
you